हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है क्लास
में? प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बता दीजिए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके वेरी गुड। तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको
हमेशा की तरह बता देता हूं कि जो आज
फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आए हैं डीएचई की
सीरीज में। तो हमने क्या किया हुआ है?
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप पे एक
ग्रुप क्रिएट किया हुआ है क्लास नोट्स के
नाम पर जहां पर हम क्या करते हैं? अपने
सारे रिसोर्सेज सारे नोट शेयर करते हैं।
तो अगर किसी भी स्टूडेंट को वह रिसोर्सेज
चाहिए, उन रिसोर्सेज का एक्सेस चाहिए या
मुझसे कोई पर्सनली डाउट पूछना है या आपकी
कोई क्वरी है या आपको प्रीवियस जितने भी
क्लासेस हुए हैं उनके नोट्स या फ्यूचर्स
में आने वाली जो भी क्लासेस हैं उनके जो
भी नोट्स हैं अगर वो सारी चीजें अब आप
लोगों को एक्सेस चाहिए चाहे वो पीपीटीस हो
पीडीएफ हो उन सभी का अगर आप लोगों को
एक्सेस चाहिए तो आप क्या कर सकते हो जो
हमारी वीडियो है वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन
में क्लास नोट्स नाम से एक लिंक दिया गया
है। तो वहां पर लिंक पे क्लिक करके आप
हमारे Telegram अह चैनल को जॉइ कर सकते
हो। उसके अलावा आप वहां पर WhatsApp ग्रुप
का भी WhatsApp चैनल का भी लिंक दिया गया
है। जहां पर आप क्या कर सकते हो? हमारे
WhatsApp चैनल को सब्सक्राइब कर सकते।
WhatsApp चैनल पर जुड़ सकते हो। जहां पर
कोई भी न्यू अनाउंसमेंट कोई भी नेक्स्ट
क्लास कब होगी या कुछ भी अनाउंसमेंट आपको
वहीं पर देखने को मिलती है। नाउ अगेन
वेलकम टू डेथिस एकडमी। आप सभी का स्वागत
है। तो अगेन गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो आज
कितने स्टूडेंट? 14 ओके अच्छी बात है।
ओके अर्पित मैं उनको बोलूंगा।
ओके तो चलिए फिर क्लास को स्टार्ट करें।
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई भी
डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ लीजिए। तो और आज की
क्लास काफी स्पेशल होने वाली है और आज के
बाद भी जितनी क्लासेस होने वाली है सारी
स्पेशल होने वाली है और आप लोगों को बता
देता हूं कि अपकमिंग जो भी सेशंस होएंगे
नेक्स्ट मैं आप लोगों के लिए जो प्लान सोच
रहा हूं वो आपका प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन और
लेटरल मूवमेंट पे सोच रहा हूं। तो जैसे ही
ये पोर्शन कंप्लीट होगा उसके बाद एक छोटा
सा पोर्शन हम करवाएंगे किसका? पावर सेल
का। क्योंकि इट इज वेरी वेरीेंट टू
अंडरस्टैंड। देन उसके बाद हम शिफ्ट करने
की कोशिश करेंगे अपने पावर प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन एंड लेटरल मूवमेंट के ऊपर अगर
सब कुछ अच्छा रहा तो अगर मैं अवेलेबल रहा
सब कुछ अच्छा रहा तो आई विल ट्राई माय
बेस्ट कि मैं आप लोगों के लिए वो जल्दी से
स्टार्ट करूंगा बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से
शुरू करके और हम बिल्कुल एक एडवांस लेवल
पे या इंटरमीडिएट लेवल पर क्या करेंगे उस
चीज को ले ले जाकर छोड़ेंगे ताकि आप कोई
भी ओएससीपी या ओएससीपी प्लस या कोई भी
एग्जाम आप ट्राई करने की कोशिश करो तो आप
आसानी से क्रैक कर लो खास करके रिलेटेड टू
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड लेटरल मूवमेंट।
तो चलिए फिर हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं
नेक्स्ट। तो आज का जो हमारा सेशन है वो
सेशन है रिलेटेड टू द ड्रॉपर। वीबीए में
आपको अगर कोई टूल है अगर आपको कोई कोड है
अगर वह ड्रॉप करना हो तो वह कैसे कर सकते
हैं? उसकी एक नॉर्मल टेक्निक के बारे में
मैं आपको डिजाइन करके दिखाऊंगा। तो सपोज
इमेजिन आप समझ लीजिए या मान लीजिए अगर
आपका जो मिलेशियस पेलोड है उसका साइज
अराउंड 50 MB या 100 MB है जो आपका जो
मिलेशियस पेलोड है उसका जो साइज है वो 50
MB या 50 MB से ज्यादा है या 100 MB है
100 MB से ज्यादा है। ओके। तो मेरा आप
लोगों से एक सवाल है कि वुड यू पिक अप इट
डायरेक्टली इंसाइड एसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट
एंड ईमेल इट टू ए टारगेट?
मतलब क्या आप
जो साइज 50 MB
या जो 100 MB के साइज का जो पेलोड है क्या
उसको आप डायरेक्ट Microsoft Word के अंदर
पैक करके ईमेल कर दोगे?
क्या आप जो पेलोड है जिसका साइज 100 MB या
50 MB है उसको
डायरेक्टली Microsoft Word के अंदर पैक
करोगे। पैक करके टारगेट के पास ईमेल कर
दोगे। क्या ऐसा आप करोगे? अगर आपके पेलोड
का साइज इतना बड़ा है क्या उसको आप
डायरेक्टली ईमेल करोगे? अगर नहीं करोगे तो
क्यों नहीं करोगे? उसका कारण बताइए। और
अगर करोगे तो कैसे करोगे?
नहीं करोगे कारण बताइए और करोगे तो कैसे
करोगे? यह भी बताइए।
न एक्स ने बोला सर नहीं करेंगे क्यों नहीं
करेंगे न एक्स
अभी जो लेवल चल रहा है जब प्रेजेंट क्लास
की मैं बता रहा हूं देखो जो सेशन स्टार्ट
होते हैं जो भी मॉड्यूल स्टार्ट होता है।
मॉड्यूल में क्या होता है कि स्टार्टिंग
में बिगिनर लेवल पर स्टार्ट होता है और
इंटरमीडिएट पर ले जाकर छोड़ दिया जाता है।
बट अभी जो प्रेजेंट सेशन चल रहा है इसकी
जो पिछली क्लास हुई थी वो इंटरमीडिएट लेवल
की थी। आज का जो है वो फिर से आप समझ सकते
हो बेसिक लेवल का है। उसके बाद इसकी जो
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी वो YouTube पर कहीं
नहीं मिलने वाला। इवन यह भी नहीं मिलने
वाला और वह तो बिल्कुल नहीं मिलने वाला।
तो उस टाइप की क्लास है।
तो देखिए
आप ऐसा बिल्कुल भी नहीं करोगे। उसका जवाब
यह है कि अगर आपके पेलोड का साइज 50 MB है
या 50 MB से ज्यादा है या मतलब जो पेलोड
का साइज है काफी बड़ा बन रहा है तो आप
उसको कभी भी डायरेक्टली Microsoft Word के
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर एंबेड करके ईमेल नहीं
करोगे। अगर आपने ऐसा किया अगर आपने ऐसा
किया तो क्या होगा? जो आपके टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
ऊपर ईमेल गेटवे के फिल्टर लगे हुए होते
हैं। जो टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है या कोई भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन खास करके जो कंपनीज होती है
उनके ऊपर जो ईमेल गेटवे होता है उनके ऊपर
फिल्टर लगे होते हैं। या जो एंटीवायरस है
हैं? वो क्या करते हैं? किसी भी अटैचमेंट
का एक साइज डिसाइड करते हैं। ठीक है? कि
इसी साइज का अटैचमेंट हम क्या करेंगे?
एक्सेप्ट करेंगे। तो इसीलिए अगर आपका जो
अटैचमेंट है उसका साइज बड़ा होगा अगर आपके
पेलोड का साइज बड़ा होगा तो डायरेक्टली
क्या होगा विदिन ए सेकंड आपका जो वो पेलोड
था वो ब्लॉक हो जाएगा या उसको क्वारंटाइन
कर दिया जाएगा क्योंकि वो सस्पिशियस माना
जाएगा क्योंकि अभी जो काम आप सोचिए किसी
को ईमेल भेजते हो इवन उसमें एक छोटा सा
वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट भेजते हो कितने का होगा
50 100 150 MB का तो नहीं होगा मुश्किल से
1 MB का भी नहीं होता कभी कबभार उसके अंदर
कोई अगर अह ज़्यादा अह फ़ज़ हैं, ज़्यादा चीज़
हैं, तभी जाके वह होता है। अदरवाइज़ तो
इतना बड़ा साइज़ नहीं होता। अब इतने बड़े
साइज का अटैचमेंट अगर आप किसी को ईमेल भेज
रहे हो, तो उसमें शक तो होगा ही
ऑब्वियसली। और आपने क्या भेजा कि आप एक
अननोन व्यक्ति हो, एक अननोन पर्सन हो
जिसने कंपनी को स्पोफ करने की कोशिश कर
रहे हो, पीसिंग ईमेल भेजने की कोशिश कर
रहे हो और आपने लिखा रिज्यूमे है और
रिज्यूुमे का साइज है आपका 100 MB ऐसा
क्या होगा आपके रिज्यूुमे में? क्या 100
MB में आपने ऐसा रिज्यूे 800 9000 पेज का
रिज्यूमे रख दिया? ऐसा तो पॉसिबल नहीं है
ना। तो इस चीज से बचने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं? जो रेटिमर्स होते हैं या जो
एडवांस अटैकर्स होते हैं वो बहुत ही
चालाकी से एक काम करते हैं। वो क्या करते
हैं? वो जो मेन डॉक्यूमेंट है उसको लाइट
वेट और क्लीन बनाते हैं। मतलब जो मेन
डॉक्यूमेंट है उसको क्या करते हैं? लाइट
वेट।
उसको लाइट वेट और क्लीन
बिल्कुल लाइट वेट और क्लीन बनाते हैं। फॉर
एग्जांपल
25 KB या 50 KB
ठीक है या ज्यादा से ज्यादा 100 KB इससे
ऊपर तो बड़ा वो डॉक्यूमेंट बनाते ही नहीं।
जो भी रे टीमर्स होते हैं या जो एडवांस
अटैकर्स होते हैं वह क्या करते हैं अपने
डॉक्यूमेंट का बस 25 KB 50 KB 100 KB या
150 KB तक का ही डॉक्यूमेंट क्या करते हैं
वो डिजाइन करते हैं इतना लाइट वेट बनाते
हैं और वो लाइट वेट कैसे बनाते हैं ठीक है
या वो लाइट लाइट वेट बनाने के लिए क्या
करते हैं उस डॉक्यूमेंट को लाइट वेट बनाने
के लिए क्या करते हैं वो यूज़ करते हैं
ड्रॉपर का किसका यूज़ करते हैं ड्रॉपर का
किसका यूज़ करते हैं वह ड्रॉपर का यूज़ करते
हैं कि अब ड्रॉपर क्या होता है? उसके बारे
में जानते हैं। व्हाट इज ड्रॉपर? ड्रॉपर
इज अ टाइप ऑफ मिनिशियस कोड और ए प्रोग्राम
डिजाइन टू इंस्टॉल और ड्रॉप अनदर पेलोड सच
एज मालवेयर बैकडोर और एन एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल ऑन टू ए सिस्टम। बेसिकली आप ड्रॉपर
को एक मिलिशियस कोड या मिलसियस प्रोग्राम
भी समझ सकते हो जिसको सिर्फ इसी पर्पस से
डिजाइन किया गया है कि वो किसी फाइल को
क्या करें? टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर ड्रॉप
करें।
टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर ड्रॉप करें। उसको
सिर्फ इसी पर्पस से डिजाइन किया जाता है।
ठीक है? या फिर आप ड्रॉपर को क्या समझ
सकते हो? ड्रॉपर को आप मिलेशियस कोड समझने
की बजाय ऐसा प्रोग्राम समझ सकते हो जो
क्या करता है? आपका जो मिलेशियस कोड है जो
आपका मिलेशियस कोड है उसको उसके कोड का
क्या करता है? उसको कैरी नहीं करता
मलेशियस कोड को बल्कि वह क्या करता है?
कूरियर बॉय की तरह काम करता है। कूरियर
बॉय क्या करता है? एक अटैचमेंट ले जाता
है। एक बॉक्स ले जाता है। उस बॉक्स में
क्या होता है? वह पेलोड होता है। तो यहां
पर क्या है कि डायरेक्टली हम डॉक्यूमेंट
के अंदर वो पेलोड नहीं लिख रहे।
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर हम क्या कर रहे हैं?
डायरेक्टली मिलिसिस कोड नहीं लिख रहे। हम
जैसे क्या कर रहे हैं? जो वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट
है उसको कूरियर बॉय की तरह यूज़ करना चाहते
हैं। तो कैसे काम करता है? इट सक्सेसफुली
इनफिल्ट्रेट द टारगेट मशीन। साइलेंटली रीच
आउट टू द कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर ओवर द
इंटरनेट इन द बैकग्राउंड। डाउनलोड द मेन
पेलोड एंड एग्जीक्यूट इट विदाउट द यूजर
इवन रियलाइजिंग इट। बेसिकली क्या करता है
कि अगर आप समझने की कोशिश करो यह सबसे
पहले टारगेट मशीन के साथ क्या करता है?
एंटर करता है। एंटर करने के बाद
बैकग्राउंड में चुपचाप जो कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर्स होता है वहां से उस पेलोड
को डाउनलोड करता है। डाउनलोड करने के बाद
चुपचाप टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर एग्जीक्यूट कर
देता है। ये काम करता है ड्रॉपर। तो
ड्रॉपर क्या हुआ? एक ऐसा प्रोग्राम जो
क्या करता है? किसी पे लोड को इंस्टॉल
करता है, ड्रॉप करता है और एग्जीक्यूट
करता है। बट अपने साथ वो कैरी नहीं करता।
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? क्सिक्वेंटली द कोर
मिलिशियस पेलोड ऑलवेज रिसाइड सेफली ऑन द
अटैकर्स कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर।
अगर एक चीज सोचोगे कि जो आपका पेलोड है,
वह कमांड कंट्रोल सर्वर पर ही रहता है। उस
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर नहीं होता। उस
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर क्या होता है? कोई
यूआरएल होता है या कोई आईपी एड्रेस होता
है जिसके थ्रू वो कम्युनिकेशन होगा। इवन
इफ द डिफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी टीम एनालाइज द
इनिशियल डॉक्यूमेंट दे विल नॉट फाइंड द
प्राइमरी पेलोड एंबेडेड इनाइडेड। ठीक है?
अगर कोई सिक्योरिटी टीम उस डॉक्यूमेंट को
एनालाइज भी करती है तो ड्यूरिंग एनालिसिस
उनको वो मिलिशियस पेलोड नहीं दिखाई देगा।
क्योंकि मिलिशियस पेड कहां पर है? कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर के ऊपर है। सी2 सर्वर
के ऊपर है। या फिर किसके ऊपर है? आपके जो
हमने सर्वर जिससे आपको पेड डाउनलोड करवाना
जहां से वहां पर है। लेकिन वो मिलिसिस कोड
आपके वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर नहीं है।
वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट में आपने इंस्ट्रक्शन दी
हुई है कि जैसे ही टारगेट सिस्टम पे आप
लैंड करोगे लैंड करते ही आपको क्या करना
है? कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश करना है।
कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश करके वहां से एक
फाइल को डाउनलोड करना है। डाउनलोड करना है
किस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पर और उस लोकेशन
फाइल को डाउनलोड करने के बाद एग्जीक्यूट
करवा देना है। यह सारे पर्पसफुली आप काम
करवाते हो विथ द हेल्प ऑफ़ ए ड्रॉपर।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन कि ड्रॉपर समझ में आ
गया? ड्रॉपर होता क्या है और हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? किसके किस बारे में बात कर रहे
हैं?
अंडरस्टुड सबको समझ में आ गया?
देखो रिप्लाई सभी लोग कीजिए ताकि आप लोगों
को और भी इंटरेस्टिंग। अभी हम प्रैक्टिकल
पार्ट पे शिफ्ट कर रहे हैं।
चलिए तो अभी हमारा सिनेरियो क्या है?
इमेजिन ए मल्टीीनेशनल साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फर्म नेम एजिस टेक कॉरपोरेशन वेयर मिस्टर
जॉन सर्व एज ए हेड ऑफ एचआर हेड ऑफ एचआर
एंड एजेस टेक हैज़ स्ट्रिक्ट नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर कंट्रोल्स क्फिगर्ड मतलब
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि अब हमें जो हमारा
सिनेरियो है जो हम डिजाइन कर रहे हैं जो
हम प्रैक्टिकली देखने वाले हैं कि एक एजेस
टेक कॉरपोरेशन नाम की एक मल्टी नेशनल
साइबर सिक्योरिटी फर्म है जहां पर क्या
करता है जो मिस्टर जोन है वो वो क्या करता
है? हेड ऑफ एचआर क्या करता है? ड्यूटी
देखता है। उसके बाद क्या है? उन्होंने
अपनी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर में क्या-क्या किया
हुआ है? फायरवॉल का यूज़ किया हुआ है और
ईमेल गेटवेज का यूज़ किया हुआ है और ईमेल
गेटवेज पर जो अटैचमेंट है अटैचमेंट का
साइज 2 MB रखा हुआ है। ईमेल गेटवेज के
अंदर जो अटैचमेंट है उसका साइज 2 MB
रिस्ट्रिक्ट किया हुआ है। और साथ के साथ
एनी डायरेक्ट एग्जीक्यूटेबल और स्ट्रिक्ट
स्क्रिप्ट एक्सटेंशन सच एजX डॉटb आर
परमानेंटली ब्लॉक्ड एट द गेटवे लेस। अब
वीबीएस आप हो सको हम अजम नहीं कर वीबीएस
नहीं ओनली डॉटb यह है वीबीएस ब्लॉक हो गया
तो आप इसको भेज ही नहीं सकते ठीक है
वीबीएस हो गया तो इसको आप भेज ही नहीं
सकते ठीक है तो बेसिकली आप समझिए कि उसने
अटैचमेंट का साइज 2 MB रखा हुआ है साथ के
साथ जो ईएक्स या डॉट बैट है जो ऐसे कुछ
मिलसियस
जो मिलेशियस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अटैच जो मिलसियस एक्सटेंशन होते हैं उनको
भी क्या कर रखा है ब्लॉक कर रखा है अंडर
दी कंडीशंस डिलीवरिंग ए हैवी पेलोड फॉर
एंबेडिंग ए डायरेक्ट एग्जीक्यूटेबल इनाइड
अ डॉक्यूमेंट इज इंपॉसिबल। अब जैसे कि
हमने बोला हमारे पेलोड का साइज अगर 50 MB
है, 100 MB है, इवन 3 MB भी है या 2 MB से
ऊपर भी है तो हमारा जो पेलोड है उसको
भेजना टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर इंपॉसिबल है। और
जब टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर इस तरह की चीज को
भेजना इंपॉसिबल है। तो यहां पर आते हैं
आपके रेड टीम ऑपरेटर्स। रेड टीम ऑपरेटर्स
क्या करते हैं? रेड टीम ऑपरेटर्स यूज करते
हैं दी आर्ट ऑफ स्टेजिंग। क्या यूज करते
हैं वह? आर्ट ऑफ स्टेजिंग। मतलब वह क्या
करते हैं कि जैसे मैंने अभी क्या बताया वो
पेलोड को कैरी नहीं करते। वह
ड्रॉप करते हैं, कम्युनिकेशन करते हैं और
ड्रॉप करते हैं और एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं।
तीन काम करते हैं। तो यह काम करने के लिए
आपका जो साइज है उसको 25 मतलब 2 MB की भी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। वो काम आपका 100 KB
के अंदर ही अंदर हो जाएगा। आपका वो काम
100 KB के अंदर ही हो जाएगा। तो
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पर चलें।
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पर चलें। आज
इतने कम स्टूडेंट्स क्यों आए हैं यार?
मुझे वेरी सरप्राइज कि या तो स्टूडेंट्स
के लिए इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक नहीं है फिर या
फिर
आई डोंट नो। देखो आज और दिन तो स्टूडेंट्स
ज्यादा आते थे। लोगों को लगता है कि मैं
फिर से थ्योरी पढ़ा रहा हूं पर थ्योरी
नहीं है। इट इज अ वेरी वेरीरी प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन जो थोड़ा सा आपको कांसेप्ट क्लियर
करना जरूरी था। ओके? तो चले फिर हम
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पर हम चलते हैं।
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पर कैसे चलेंगे? चलो
मिनिमाइज करते हैं। इसको हम क्लोज कर देते
हैं। इसको मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं। इसको
मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं। नाउ गो टू आवर MS
Word और MS Word पे मैं डिजाइन करूंगा और
एग्जीक्यूट और कहीं करूंगा। तब तक के लिए
मैं एक काम करता हूं। एक नया ब्लैंक
डॉक्यूमेंट लेते हैं। नया ब्लैंक
डॉक्यूमेंट और अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
बिल्कुल
जीरो से डिजाइन करने वाले हैं। तो सबसे
पहले बिल्कुल ध्यान से देखिए हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? कैसे डिजाइन करने वाले हैं।
बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल पेलोड ही डिजाइन
करूंगा। यहां पर भी मैं कुछ भी ऐसा नहीं
होगा कि जो प्रोफेशनल अनप्रोफेशनल हो। तो
सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं? गो टू इंसर्ट
टैब। इंसर्ट टैब से हम गो टू हेडर विद अ
हेडर
इंसर्ट एंड
गो टू हेडर टैब एंड गो टू ब्लैंक। ब्लैंक
हेडर। यहां पर वी विल एक टेबल इंसर्ट
करेंगे। टेबल दो को हम रखेंगे दो कॉलम
वाली टेबल। ये रहा। एक टेबल को हमने
इंसर्ट किया यहां पर। और अब इसके अंदर हम
क्या करते हैं? इसको सेलेक्ट करने के बाद
इसको डिजाइन करते हैं। टेबल डिजाइन में
हमने बॉर्डर स्टाइल पहले इसको कलर सेट कर
देते हैं। इसका कलर सेट करने के लिए मैं
कस्टम कलर रखता हूं। कस्टम कलर में मैं
क्या करता हूं?
बॉर्डर को भी ऑफ कर देंगे। और
इसका हम रखते हैं नेवी ब्लू तो हैशटग
मैंने लिखा हुआ है ये
हिट एंटर ओके कंट्रोल z
एंड एंड
ओके इसका हम कलर नहीं इसको हम कलर नहीं
करने वाले हम सिर्फ क्या करने वाले हैं जो
बॉर्डर्स हैं बॉर्डर्स को नो बॉर्डर्स कर
देते हैं इसको भी हम क्या कर देते हैं
बॉर्डर को नो बॉर्डर कर ओके अभी यहां पर
कोई भी बॉर्डर नहीं है। इतना पता चल गया।
अभी हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं? एक हेडिंग
पेस्ट करेंगे। कौन सी? यह रही एजेस टेक
कॉर्पोरेशन इंटरप्राइज सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम।
इसको भी हम यहां पर कर देते हैं पेस्ट।
गुड।
यहां पर करते हैं पेस्ट। यहां पर हमने
पेस्ट किया। देन उसके अलावा दूसरी जो
हेडिंग थी उसको यहां पर हम कहां पेस्ट
करते हैं? ये रहा कॉन्फिडेंशियल ये ये
उसके राइट साइड में पेस्ट करेंगे।
ओके। और आपको अगर ऐसे समझ में नहीं आया तो
मैं इसको एक काम कर देता हूं। थोड़ी देर
के लिए इसको बॉर्डर को ऑल बॉर्डर कर देता
हूं। सो दैट कि
ठीक आपको अभी समझ में आ जाएगा। तो अभी हम
इसको क्या करते हैं? इस दोनों को सेलेक्ट
करते हैं। एंड गो टू इंसर्ट यहां पर हम
रखते हैं
कैलिब्री ये साइज रख लेते हैं ताकि अच्छा
लगे। एंड इसको हम रखते हैं अराउंड
9 पॉइंट।
ओके 9 पॉइंट रखते हैं। इसका बोल्ड कर देते
हैं। बोल्ड भी हो गया। बोल्ड 9 पॉइंट।
ओके। अब इसका भी हम साइज डिसाइड कर देंगे।
ये तो हमारा इस साइड रहेगा बिल्कुल कोने
में। और इसका साइज रखते हैं हम। ये रहा
नेवी ब्लू। और इसका जो इसको डिजाइन जो हम
करने वाले हैं। इसका साइज हम एट रखते हैं।
एट रखते हैं और यहां कोनेम कर देते हैं।
और इसका जो साइज हम डिसाइड करने वाले हैं
ये हमारा रहेगा। ये रहा। नहीं यह रहा
कॉन्फिडेंशियल इंटरनल यूज़ ओनली यहां पर
हमने ऐसा कर दिया डार्क ओके एंड उसके बाद
हम क्या कर देते हैं
इसको जो टेबल है पेज का टेबल का जो
बॉर्डर्स है उसको हम हटा देते हैं 1 मिनट
बिल्कुल काम हम प्रोफेशनल ही करते हैं।
अदरवाइज हम काम ही नहीं करेंगे। तो अभी
बिल्कुल प्रोफेशनल लग रहा है आपको नहीं लग
रहा तो बता देना।
और इसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? गो टू
इंसर्ट टैब गो टू आवर एंड इस वन
होम एंड गो टू आवर होम टैब ऑर्डर टैब और
यहां हमने बॉटम बॉर्डर ऐड कर दिया। तो मे
बी इट इज मोर प्रोफेशनल देन और यहां से हम
आउट कर लेते हैं। अच्छा दिख रहा है सबको
परफेक्टली
सही दिख रहा है या मैं एक काम करते हैं।
इसको थोड़ा सा और ज़ूम कर देता हूं आप
लोगों को। अब सही दिख रहा है?
चलो यहां तक हमने ये कर लिया। देन उसके
बाद हम क्या करते हैं? एक और फेक बॉक्स
बनाते हैं। एक और फेस फेक बॉक्स बनाएंगे
ताकि हम क्या कर सकें?
टेबल बना सके। तो चलिए फिर हम अभी फिर से
लास्ट टाइम इंसर्ट एंड
यह आ गया हमारा यहां पर। और अभी हम क्या
करते हैं?
इसका डिजाइन करते हैं इसको। इसको डिजाइन
करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं? शेड। शेड
के अंदर जाएंगे हम। यहां पर अभी मेंशन
करेंगे क्या? कलर
[संगीत]
एवी
ओके
लाइट कर अभी लाइट सॉफ्ट ब्लू भाई बेसिकली
सॉफ्ट ब्लू कलर हमने यहां पर ऐड कर लिया।
उसके बाद जो बॉर्डर लाइन थी उसको हम क्या
करते हैं? बॉर्डर स्टाइल सेम है। इसका जो
साइज है यह सही है। ये साइज ये रखते हैं
साइज। ये
ओके। ये भी सही है। परफेक्टली फाइन। और
बॉर्डर स्टाइल भी सही है। देन उसके बाद हम
कलर रखें तो बॉर्डर का कलर भी हम क्या कर
लेते हैं? एंड लिटिल ब्लू या ये रख लेते
हैं ताकि आपको अच्छा भी लगे। ये रहा
कंफर्टेबल ये रहा एंड ये रहा। हमने बॉर्डर
डिजाइन कर लिया। नाउ इसके बाद हम इसके
अंदर क्या करते हैं? अभी एक्चुअल कंटेंट
लिखते हैं जो हमें यूज़ करना है।
तो इसमें डबल क्लिक करते हैं। डबल क्लिक
करने के बाद हम अपना कंटेंट उठाते हैं।
क्यों सुनाई नहीं दे रहा आप लोगों को?
ये तो सिंपल है यार। इसमें क्या करना है?
क्या सबको मेरी आवाज नहीं आ रही? बताओ
बताओ।
चलो यहां पर एक काम करते हैं। कंट्रोल वी
और इसको हम
कंट्रोल वी और इसका कितना साइज रखते हैं
हम? नॉर्मली कितना साइज रहेगा सही?
इसको साइज रखते हैं हम। यह रहा।
के एंड्री एंड इसका साइज रखते हैं 12
बोल्ड देन उसके बाद
बोल्ड डाल
इसका कलर भी रख देते हैं हम
डार्क रेड सही रहेगा ये ओके देन उसके बाद
नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे भी हम डिजाइन करते
हैं एंड उसका साइज रखेंगे हम नॉर्मली
क्योंकि मैं आराम से बोल रहा हूं यार
इसलिए कम आ रही होगी आप लोगों को। यहां तक
हमने क्या कर लिया? डिजाइन कर लिया।
कंट्रोल सी और यह रहा
सॉरी। यहां पर पेस्ट कर दिया हमने। यहां
पर हमने पेस्ट कर दिया।
और इसको क्या करता हूं? अभी और भी कम कर
देता हूं।
इसको रख देता हूं। एक पॉइंट और
बिल्कुल सही है। एंड परफेक्टली फाइन ये
रहा।
एंड इसको भी हम क्या करने वाले हैं? यह
बोल्ड
इन तीनों को हम क्या कर देंगे? बोल्ड कर
देंगे। उसके बाद यह रहा।
इसको हम क्या करने वाले हैं? इसको साइज
करने वाले हैं। एंड
परफेक्टली फाइन एंड
एंड इसको रखते हैं हम। यह रहा परफेक्टली
बार सही है। अभी ऐसे कर देते हैं। परफेक्ट
डिजाइन हो गया।
अभी सही है। क्योंकि लास्ट टाइम हमने जो
मिस्टेक की थी ना जो हम इसको पॉप अप को
हटाने आज पहले उसी की प्रैक्टिस करके आगे
बढ़ेंगे।
ओसीपी के लिए तो एनफ अभी नहीं है। ओएससीपी
के लिए तो और भी ज्यादा पढ़ना पड़ेगा। बट
ये मेरी स्किल उससे ज्यादा की है। ठीक है?
ओएससीपी में इतना ज्यादा नहीं करना
पड़ेगा। ओएससीपी में तो आपको वनेबल
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती है। टूल्स का यूज़
करना पड़ता है। बट ये वाली चीजें नहीं
करनी पड़ती इतनी ज्यादा। ये आपका
प्रैक्टिकल एक्सपीरियंस है रियल लाइफ के
साथ। क्योंकि आपको पता होना चाहिए कैसे
आपका पेलोड डेवलपमेंट की स्टार्टिंग होती
है। तो बिल्कुल बेसिक पेलोड्स हैं। यह
डिटेक्ट हो जाते हैं। सेम टाइम कोई भी यह
इवेज पेड नहीं है। जैसे इसको रन करोगे ये
डिटेक्ट हो जाएंगे। बट आपको मैं आईडिया दे
रहा हूं कि कैसे डेवलपमेंट होती है, कितनी
मेहनत लगती है। इवेज पेलोड तो आपको लिए
स्पेशल ट्रेनिंग लेनी पड़ेगी उसके लिए। तो
यहां तक हमारा यह हो गया। उसके बाद मैं एक
और काम कर लेता हूं। अब एक और चीज है
हमारे पास।
एक और टेबल ऐड करते हैं। दिक कोई बैनर ये
रहा।
एंड ये रहा कंट्रोल वी। ये हो गया हमारा।
और इसको भी हम क्या करेंगे? अभी
बोल्ड करते हैं। गोल्ड इसको करते हैं हम
14 बिकॉज़ 14 करके और इसका हम कलर रखते
हैं। इसका भी कलर सेलेक्ट करते हैं हम।
इसका कलर रखेंगे हम डार्क नेवी ब्लू।
हो गया। और ये इसका कलर भी सेट हो गया।
परफेक्टली फाइन। और इसको हम यहां पर ले
आते हैं। और एक और टेबल बनाते हैं। जहां
पर हम क्या रखने वाले हैं? टेबल में
यहां पर हमने टेबल बना ली। और टेबल के
अंदर सबसे पहले हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
इधर
ये रही एम्प्लॉय आईडी। और ये सब चीजें हम
लिख देंगे कंट्रोल सी एंड
हो गया एम्प्लॉय डी एम्प्लॉय नेम और
डिपार्टमेंट व्हाट हैपन
यही तो समस्या है।
रिमिंग के लिए आपको मास्टर तो करना
पड़ेगा।
पython तो आपका एटलीस्ट आनी चाहिए। आपको
पथन आनी चाहिए।
अदरवाइज यू कांट डू एनीथिंग।
पython तो आपको आनी चाहिए, रस्ट आनी
चाहिए। बाकी आजकल एआई है ना इतनी जरूरत
नहीं है। बस आपको एआई से काम करवाना आना
चाहिए। इसके बाद तो आप सबसे जरूरी है अब
एआई से आपका काम करवाना आना चाहिए।
अगर वो करवाना आपको आता है तो यू कांट डू
एनीथिंग। कुछ भी कर सकते हो आप। ठीक है?
कुछ भी आप कर सकते हो। तो अगर आपको ऐसा
कुछ आता है तो
बिल्कुल परफेक्टली फाइन और इसको हम एक काम
कर देते हैं अभी के लिए
सेंट्री लाइन एंड इनका सब कुछ सही है
परफेक्टली फाइन एंड
इसकी शेडिंग सेट करते हैं टेड टेबल डिजाइन
में इसकी शेडिंग हम सेट करेंगे
एंड
डार्क ब्लू
एंड इसका जो
कलर है इसके लिए हम रखेंगे वाइट परफेक्टली
फाइनली
इसको कर देते हैं बोल्ड हो गया और ये जो
बाकी जो चीजें बच गई इसको हम कर देते हैं
अभी के लिए टेबल डिजाइन इस हम करते हैं
ओके तो आई होप कि एक अभी एक प्रोफेशनल
टेबल बन गई होगी प्रोफेशनल बिल्कुल लुकिंग
है। बिल्कुल सही दिख रहा है सब कुछ?
सब कुछ सही दिखाई दे रहा है? बिल्कुल
परफेक्टली। तो यहां तक तो हमारा सब कुछ हो
गया। अभी हम क्या करते हैं? नीचे वाले
पार्ट को सेलेक्ट करते हैं और कंट्रोल डी
कंट्रोल डी करने के बाद इसको हिडन पर
क्लिक करते हैं और ओके कर दिया। इसको हाइड
कर दिया। तो यहां तक तो सब कुछ सही था। अब
आते हैं हमारे कोड पर। तो इसको सबसे पहले
हम क्या करते हैं? सेव करते हैं। सेव एज
आई विल गो टू माय
डॉक्यूमेंट्स। एंड इसका मैं नाम रखता हूं
अभी के लिए।
कुछ भी नाम रख लेते हैं हम।
बाकी हम नाम रखें तो ना रखें तो क्या
रखें? इसका नाम रखते हैं प्रोटेक्टेड
डॉक्यूमेंट।
डॉक्यूमेंट्स और अभी मैं सेलेक्ट कर रहा
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल मै इनेबल्ड और सेव कर
लिया। यहां तक सेव हो गया। कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। हो गया। परफेक्टली फाइन। अभी हम
चलते हैं डेवलपर टैब के अंदर। डेवलपर टैब
के अंदर विजुअल बेसिक्स एंड डबल क्लिक
यहां पर आ गए। तो अभी हम कोड करना स्टार्ट
करते हैं और कोड में लिखते हैं। सबसे पहले
आपको पता है ऑप्शन एक्सप्लसिट।
ओके। मैं इसको वो करता हूं अभी के लिए।
एक्सप्लसिट। कहीं पर स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक
होती है तो प्लीज टेल मी।
ठीक है।
प्राइवेट
सब डॉक्यूमेंट
डॉक्यूमेंट अंडरस्कोर ओपन
एंड नेक्स्ट अब हम क्या करते हैं?
ऑन
रिज्यूम नेक्स्ट
एक फंक्शन कॉल कर रहा हूं। यहां पर मैं
एग्जीक्यूट एंड
एग्जीक्यूट पेलोड
पेलोड एंड
एंड अनहाइड
अनहाइड नाम का एक फंक्शन यहां पर मैं बना
रहा हूं। यह फंक्शन मैंने यहां पर बनाया
और उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
प्राइवेट
ऑटो ओपन
ओके स्पेलिंग गड़बड़ है
प्राइवेट सब
ये हो गया और इसके बाद सेम यहां पर कॉल कर
देते इस फंक्शन को
कंट्रोल सी
अब उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? इस फंक्शन
का डिजाइन करते हैं। तो फंक्शन को डिजाइन
करने के लिए हम प्राइवेट कॉल ये रहा। इस
फंक्शन का नेम सेम लेंगे। बिकॉज़ अदरवाइज
टाइप और एरर नहीं होने चाहिए।
ये हमारा फंक्शन बन गया। अब फंक्शन में हम
सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं?
सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं अभी?
सबसे पहले एक वेरिएबल डिक्लेअर करते हैं।
डॉक एच डॉक्यूमेंट
उसके बाद सेट वेरिएबल
इक्वल टू
एक्टिव डॉक्यूमेंट
देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? एक
एप्लीकेशन डॉट
स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग
स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग परफेक्टली फाइन एंड
इक्वल टू फॉल्स।
स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग इक्वल टू फॉल्स क्यों
लिखा है? इसका मतलब क्या है कि जब भी
आपके स्क्रीन में आपने क्या किया है? एक
चीज को छुपाया हुआ है। जब भी आपकी स्क्रीन
पर कुछ भी जो विजिबल चेंजेस होने वाला है
और विजिबल चेंजेस की वजह से जो भी
फ्लिकिंग होने वाली है और फ्लिकिंग की वजह
से जो भी चीजें फ्रीज होने वाली है या
इधर-उधर होने वाली है उनको क्या करे? ये
उनको ये स्टॉप करे। मतलब क्या है कि एक
चुपचाप बैकग्राउंड में वह जो फ्लिकरिंग है
जो भी चेंजेज होना लेआउट के साथ वर्ड के
अंदर वह सब कुछ बदल जाए लेकिन क्या है कि
जो यूज़र्स है उसकी स्क्रीन पर दिखाई ना दे
उस चीज को छुपाने के लिए हमने इसको यूज़
किया है। नेक्स्ट अभी हम क्या करते हैं वो
टेबल को डिलीट करते हैं। इफ
डॉक्स डॉट टेबल
टेबल्स काउंट
टेबल्स काउंट ओके
एंड ग्रेटर देन जीरो
देन
डॉक डॉट
टेबल्स डॉट डिलीट
डॉट डिलीट उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं।
इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं एंड इफ को।
क्योंकि अभी मैं देखने वाला हूं कि जो
एक्चुअल में मैं डिजाइन करने वाला हूं मैं
क्योंकि ड्रॉपर डिजाइन कर रहा हूं। थोड़ा
सा प्रोफेशनल होना चाहिए मेरा ड्रॉपर।
इसका जो ड्रॉपर है मेरा थोड़ा सा
प्रोफेशनल होना चाहिए। और अभी आप देखो आज
स्टूडेंट्स कितने आए हैं। लिटरली आप ही
लोग बताओ कि कैसे हमेशा देखो बीच-बीच में
आपको जब तक डांटनी पड़ती है ना जब तक मैं
आपको कोई धमकी नहीं देता। जब तक आपको नहीं
डरता जब तक मैं क्लासेस बीच में बंद नहीं
करता तब तक तब आप लोग नहीं है सपोर्ट नहीं
करते। देखो अभी क्या है आज भी वही सेम
हालत है। 9 8 10 स्टूडेंट है वही आएंगे
बाकी नहीं आएंगे। फिर से मैं अभी आप लोगों
को वार्निंग दूंगा ना और आप लोगों को
बोलूंगा कि नहीं आज से क्लास नहीं होगी।
फिर से आओगे। मुझे लगता है कि आप मेरे को
बार-बार नहीं टेस्ट कर रहे हो कि हां सचिन
सर ऐसा कुछ नहीं कर सकते और लिटरली मैं
बता रहा हूं कि मैं ऐसा कुछ बहुत कुछ कर
सकता हूं जो आपकी उम्मीद से परे हो।
कंटेंट डॉट
फों्ट डॉट
हिडन इक्व फॉल्स
फॉल्स ठीक है हिडन डॉट फॉल्स हो गया यहां
तक हमने क्या कर दिया अभी हिडन डॉट फॉल्स
क्यों लिखा कि जो रियल टेबल है ठीक है जो
अभी तक हमने क्या किया जो रियल टेबल है जो
हेडिंग थी उसको हमने हाइड किया हुआ है उस
को हम क्या करना चाहते हैं अभी विज़िबल
करना चाहते हैं जो भी चीज हमने हाइड की है
उसको हम शो करना चाहते हैं इसलिए हमने ये
लाइन यूज़ की है। देन उसके बाद एक और कोड
है
एप्लीकेशन डॉट
स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग।
स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग
इक्वल टू फाल्स से सेम स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग
इक्वल टू ट्रू। अभी ट्रू कर दिया उस
फ्लकरिंग इफेक्ट को करने के लिए कम करने
के लिए। देन एक और हम क्या कर रहे हैं?
एक्टिव
ये एज इट इज़ आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। इसमें कुछ
भी चेंज करने की जरूरत नहीं है। जब इस
तरीके का कंटेंट आप यूज़ करने वाले हो। जिस
तरीके से मैं डिजाइन कर रहा हूं। टाइप
इक्वल टू
डब्ल्यू डी प्रिंट
प्रिंट व्यू। यहां तक हो गया। अब उसके बाद
हम क्या करते हैं? एक मैसेज बॉक्स भी
डिजाइन कर लेते हैं।
वही तो समस्या है अनोनिमस आप लोग नहीं
मेरे को मजबूर करते हो आप मेरी एफिशिएंसी
चेक कर रहे हो कि मैं आप लोग को क्या करवा
रहा हूं क्या नहीं और आप लोग ऐसे
एफिशिएंसी चेक करना चाहते हो तो भैया फिर
तो मैं आपकी एफिशिएंसी जब चेक करने लगूंगा
तो फिर देखना कैसे एफिशिएंसी चेक होगी
मुझे पता है कि अभी तक आप जो सीखने आए हो
अब तक स्टार्ट नहीं हुआ है बट सिनेरियो के
बेस पर स्टार्ट होगा
मैसेज बॉक्स
हार्डवेयर सिक्योरिटी
टोकन वेरीाइड
मैं इतना ही यूज़ कर रहा हूं इसको। ठीक है?
वेरीफ़ाई। बस इतना ही यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैसेज
बॉक्स को। उसके अलावा इसमें और कुछ नहीं
यूज़ करने वाला मैं।
ओके? फाइन। अब इसको एक काम करते हैं। हम
रन करके देखेंगे। बट रन करने से पहले हमें
हमें क्या करना है? इसको ज़ेरॉक्स बना के
रखना पड़ेगा पूरे डॉक्यूमेंट का। कंट्रोल S
तो मैंने कर लिया। सेव कर लिया। इसको मैं
क्लोज भी कर दूंगा। अभी के लिए मैंने इसको
क्लोज कर दिया। एंड विच क्लोज किया। और
इसका जो एक और सेव एज बना के रखता हूं।
कहीं पर डॉक्यूमेंट
डश कॉपी
जीरो वन ओके और इसको भी मैं वहीं पर सेव
करके रखता हूं।
ठीक है? और अभी मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता
हूं। इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं। इसको
मिनिमाइज कर देते हैं। इसको मिनिमाइज
क्लोज ही कर देते हैं। इसका काम ही खत्म
हो गया। उसके बाद तो सारा मुझे कोड खुद से
रिाइन करना है। तो अभी हम चलते हैं अपने
डॉक्यूमेंट्स के अंदर। डॉक्यूमेंट्स के
अंदर हमारा क्या था? ये रहा कैपिटल में
डबल क्लिक किया ये रहा इस तरीके से है
प्रोटेक्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट इन
एमआईपी इंक्रिप्टेड वाया इंक्रिप्शन की
मैनेजमेंट सर्विस है क्लासिफाइड
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड है क्लिक इनेबल एडिटिंग इन
येलो नोटिफिकेशन बार एट द टॉप या क्लिक
इनेबल कंटेंट एट येलो हार्डवेयर
सिक्योरिटी टोकन वेरिफिकेशन डॉक्यूमेंट
कंटेंट सो ब्ल ब्ल ब्ल और हम एक काम कर
रहे हैं इसको इनेबल कंटेंट किया अभी ओके
ओके एक प्रॉब्लम थी कहां पर
यहां पर
एक्टिव
स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक
एस सी टी आई पी ई एक्टिव डॉक्यूमेंट इसको
अभी के लिए मैं कंट्रोल एस करूं फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी इसको हम रन करते हैं अभी एक
और है
अपडेटिंग
देखो
जैसे मैंने रन किया इस तरीके से आएगा कि
हार्डवेयर सिक्योरिटी टोकन वेरीिफाइड ओके
हो गया मैं इसको अभी क्या करता हूं
अभी मैं इसको कुछ क्लोज कर देता हूं हो
गया इतना ही देन तो मैं क्लोज करूं तो
इतना ही था यह रहा यह आ गया आपकी दिख रहा
है यह दिख रहा है टेबल आ गई आपकी
टेबल आ गई आप लोगों को यह चीज
यही चीज हमें चाहिए थी। जैसे मैं अभी फिर
से इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं। मैं इसको
क्लोज ही कर देता हूं। डोंट सेव। मैं इसको
सेव नहीं किया। फिर से मैं डबल क्लिक
किया।
इनेबल कंटेंट करता हूं मैं। [संगीत]
ओके माय गॉड।
व्हाट हैपन?
ओके
अपडेटिंग
कंट्रोल एस
अपडेटिंग कंट्रोल एस इसको मैं फिर से
क्लोज कर देता हूं।
इसको फिर से क्लोज कर देता हूं। डबल क्लिक
क्योंकि छोटी-छोटी चीजें हमें जिसको टेस्ट
करना है। इनेबल कंटेंट हार्डवेयर
सिक्योरिटी टोकन वेरीिफाइड। ओके। मैं इसको
क्लोज कर दे रहा हूं। अभी हो गया। हो गया।
परफेक्टली फाइन।
परफेक्टली फाइन। अभी हम क्या करते हैं?
अपना एक्चुअल कोड डिजाइन करते हैं। ठीक
है? अभी हम यहां पर क्या करते हैं? अपना
एक्चुअल कोड डिजाइन करते हैं। मशियस वाला।
करें।
ओके। तो अभी हम इसको क्या करते हैं? अभी
गो टू आवर विजुअल बेसिक और यहां पर कोड
डिजाइन करते हैं एक्चुअल वाला। तो अभी
होगा क्या? इसी के अंदर डिजाइन करेंगे हम।
तो इसी के अंदर हम डिजाइन करते हैं। तो
कहां पर करेंगे? तो सबसे पहले हम क्या कर
रहे हैं?
हम हम
इसी के अंदर सबसे पहले हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? एप्लीकेशन स्क्रीन अपडेटिंग इक्वल टू
फॉल्स कर दिया। इससे भी पहले हम हां फॉल्स
के बाद हम क्या कर रहे हैं? अपन स्टेज
डिजाइन कर रहे हैं।
इसी के अंदर डिजाइन करने वाले हैं। ये
रहा।
यहां लिख रहे हैं हम
स्टेज।
वन हम लिख रहे हैं पेलोड।
ड्रॉपर
पेलोड ड्रॉपर
यह हो गया
परफेक्टली फाइन अभी हम पेलोड ड्रॉपर
डिजाइन करते हैं डम उसके बाद हम क्या करते
हैं यूआरएल एज स्ट्रिंग
एज स्ट्रिंग उसके बाद
टेंपरेरी पाथ
टाइम पाथ उसके बाद एज स्ट्रिंग
स्ट्रिंग उसके बाद डम उसके बाद पीएस
स्क्रिप्ट पावर स्केल स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट
के लिए एक वेरिएबल डिजाइन कर रहे हैं
स्ट्रिंग उसके बाद एक और वेरिएबल डिजाइन
कर रहे हैं हम किसके लिए सेल कोड के लिए
सेल कमांड के लिए
हो गया चार वेरिएबल हमने डिजाइन किया है।
अब यहां एक काम करते हैं हम यहां पर एक
कमेंट देता हूं।
मशीन
पोस्टेड पे लोड यूआरएल पे लोड यूआरएल।
चलो यहां पर हम लिखते हैं यूआरएल
एचtटीपी ये मेरी काली लinक्स मशीन का आईपी
एड्रेस देता हूं। ओके 192.168
192168.119.134
ओके और पोर्ट नंबर कौन सा यूज़ करने वाला
हूं मैं? पोर्ट नंबर यूज़ करने वाला हूं 80
उसके बाद उसका नाम रहेगा पेलोड का नाम
अपडेट
exc जो MSF वेनम से मैं क्रिएट करूंगा।
अपडेट exc
देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं टेंपरेरी
पाथ का वो करते हैं सेव करते हैं तो चलो
फिर चलते हैं टेम पाथ टी एमपी पी ए टी एच
टेम पाथ उसके बाद ई एन वी
आई
ओ आर एन एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल यहां पर कॉल
कर रहे हैं। एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल कॉल
करने का एक नया तरीका यह रहा
टी एम पी
यह रहा टीएम एंड एम परसेंट
एंड
फाइल डॉट exe के अंदर हम सेव कर देंगे।
फाइल डॉट exc के अंदर हम इसको सेव कर
देंगे।
नेक्स्ट अभी हम क्या करते हैं? पावर सेल
स्क्रिप्ट डिजाइन करते हैं। तो चलो फिर
पावर सेल कमांड कंस्ट्रक्शन
पावर सेल
कमांड कंस्ट्रक्शन
पावर सेल कमांड कंस्ट्रक्शन नाउ कैसे करते
हैं टीएस
इसके लिए आपको पावर सेल आनी चाहिए और डोंट
वरी पावर सेल नेक्स्ट इसका जो नेक्स्ट है
उसमें सबसे पहले मैं पावर सेल क्लियर
करूंगा देन उसके बाद मैं आगे आपको
पढ़ाऊंगा क्योंकि प्रिलज एस्केलेशन लेटरल
मूवमेंट वगैरह में पावर सेल की बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरत पड़ती है। इनवोक वेब
रिक्वेस्ट
अरे क्या ये पावर सेल की कमांड है। इनवोक
वेब रिक्वेस्ट
हफन यूआरआई उसके बाद सिंगल कोट देन उसके
बाद डबल कोट उसके बाद एमसेंट
यूआरएल एमसेंट
सिंगल को डबल कोट फिर सिंगल कोट देन उसके
बाद हफन आउट फाइल
हफन आउट फाइल उसके बाद
सिंगल कोट फिर डबल डबल कोट उसके बाद
फिर से टेम पाथ वेरिएबल टसेंट डबल कोट
सिंगल कोट
उसके बाद सेमी कॉललन
उसके बाद हम क्या करें स्टार्ट प्रोसेस
इसी के अंदर
स्टार्ट
प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट स्टार्ट प्रोसेस
उसके बाद एक और हफन फाइल पाथ
फाइल पाथ सिंगल कोट डबल कोट
उसके बाद एमसेंट
टी ई एम पी पाथ एमसेंट
सिंगल कोट
डबल कोट सिंगल कोट डबल कोट इसको हमने
क्लोज कर दिया ये थी हमारी एक्चुअल कमांड
देन उसके उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं? सेल
एग्जीक्यूशन। अभी हमने ये तो क्या किया?
हमने उसको ड्रॉप कर दिया। ड्रॉप कर दिया।
अब उसके बाद उसको एग्जीक्यूट भी करेंगे।
ड्रॉप एंड एग्जीक्यूट दोनों करेंगे। चलो
फिर एग्जीक्यूशन ये तो हमने कमांड सेव की
है। तो नेक्स्ट कमांड सेव तो कर ली। अब
बात करते हैं सेल एग्जीक्यूशन कमांड।
सेल
एग्जीक्यूशन
कमांड। तो हम क्या करेंगे? उसका एक
वेरिएबल था हमारे पास सेल सीएमडी इक्वल
चलो फिर नेक्स्ट पावर सेलxc
पावर सेल डॉट exc
एंड
ये कर चुके हैं आप पहले ईएक्स
एग्जीक्यूशन
पॉलिसी
बाईपास
हफन
विंडो
स्टाइल
हिडन
हफन
कमांड उसके बाद ट्रिपल कोट
ट्रिपल सिंगल कोट उसके बाद यह रहा पीएस
स्क्रिप्ट
कैंपस चेंज
एक दो तीन उसके बाद फोर्थ वन सिंगल कोट
देन उसके बाद क्या करते हैं
सेल कमांड
कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन
एग्जीक्यूशन साइलेंटली
इन बैकग्राउंड
इन बैकग्राउंड उसके लिए हम आपको सबको पता
है अब क्या हम इसके इसका यूज़ करते हैं सेल
सेल उसके बाद सेल सीएमडी
वीबी हाइड हाइड करना है
ओके देन नीचे आपको पता ही है वो टेबल
डिलीट करने के लिए
ठीक ठीक है? कोड लिखा हुआ है। उसके बाद ये
रहा मैसेज बॉक्स ये बला बला।
तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
सबको समझ में आ गया
कैसे हमने लिखा?
यस या नो बताइए। तब तक के लिए मैं एक काम
कर लेता हूं। मशीन कौन कर लेता है?
क्योंकि यहां पे कोड सेव नहीं होगा। उसका
रीजन है क्योंकि मेरे में एंटीवायरस ऑन
है। जिसकी वजह सेम टाइम इसको ब्लॉक कर
देगा। रियल टाइम प्रोटेक्शन ऑन है। तो
यहां पर चलते हैं। सबसे पहले इधर चलते
हैं।
काली नेक्स्ट भी यूज़ करेंगे और Windows का
भी यूज़ करेंगे।
मुझे लगता है आप लोगों का इंटरेस्ट खत्म
हो चुका है क्लासेस से।
मैं समझ गया आप लोगों का इंटरेस्ट खत्म हो
चुका है इसीलिए आप ऐसा कर रहे हो तो एक
काम करता हूं मैं एक कोड था ना हमने यहां
पर डिजाइन किया था ये रहा कॉपी वन को
उठाते हैं यहां पर पटक लेते हैं कॉपी वन
को उठाया यहां पर पटक लेते हैं ड्रैग एंड
ड्रॉप नहीं हुआ तो कॉपी कर लेते हैं इसको
कॉपी एंड पेस्ट कर दिया यहां पर आ चुका है
इसको हम क्या करते हैं डबल क्लिक किया
अभी मैं कहीं पर इनेबल कंटेंट नहीं करने
वाला। मैं क्या करता हूं? डेवलपर मोड
विजुअल बेसिक्स
ओके इसको ओपन करते हैं। और इस पूरे कंटेंट
को मैं रिप्लेस कर देता हूं अब ये वाले
कंटेंट के साथ। कंट्रोल ऑल कंट्रोल सी और
यहां पे इसको क्या कर कंट्रोल ऑल कंट्रोल
वी।
ओके ये हमने कर लिया। और इसको मैं अगर
कंट्रोल एस करूं तो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
कंट्रोल S हो चुका है। इसको मैं क्लोज कर
देता हूं। इसको भी मैं अभी क्लोज कर देता
हूं। नेक्स्ट गो टू आवर काली लinक्स मशीन।
हमें क्या करना है? पेलोड भी जनरेट करना
है। तो पेलोड जनरेट करते हैं। चलो भैया
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हमें पेलोड जनरेट करने
में।
कर लेंगे। पेलोड जनरेट करना। कौन सी बड़ी
बात है?
व्हाट हैपन?
ऐसा मत करना भैया।
गुड सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं? आईपी चेक
करते हैं।
इफ कॉन्फिग करेक्टली ये हमारा आईपी एड्रेस
है। तो चलो एमएसएफ
वेनम
एमएसएफ वेनम hfन पी विंडोज
एंड x64
क्योंकि मेरी मेरी मशीन का वर्जन यही है।
भाई मीटर प्रेटर
मीटर प्रेटर एम ई टी
स्पेलिंग के लिए बोल देना अभी के लिए वरना
घूमते रहेंगे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिवर्स टीसीp एल होस्ट इक्वल
19216819
उसके बाद एलप
एंड 44 44 44 हफन फाइल टाइप exc
टाइप हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं exco
आउटपुट किसके अंदर सेव करने वाले हैं हम
अपडेट
अपडेट डॉट
exe
मे बी यही होगा हमारे पास आगे देखेंगे हम
तो यहां पर देख लेते हैं अपडेट exc
हां अपडेट exc यही है अपडेट exc
इसको क्या करते हैं एक काम के लिए
हिट एंटर
पे लोड जनरेटेड
एलएस अपडेट extxc हमारे पास अवेलेबल है।
उसके बाद अभी हमें क्या करना है? अभी हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? सबसे बेस्ट चीज है
एक Python सर्वर स्टार्ट करेंगे जिससे
हमारी फाइल किसके पास जाएगी? टारगेट
सिस्टम के पास। तो चलो
Python 3
hन
m
http
डॉट सर्वर
उसके बाद 80
हिट एंटर सर्वर इज स्टार्टेड और एक और
हमें टैब ओपन करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
नेक्स्ट टैब है। इसके ऊपर हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? यूज़ करने वाले हैं। एमएसएफ
हफ
मोड
व्हाट हैपन?
यह क्या प्रॉब्लम हो रही है?
यही तो है प्रॉब्लम क्या है
ओके ओके ओके सॉरी सॉरी एमएसएफ कंसोल
हफन क
यह भी तो प्रॉब्लम है।
यह प्रॉब्लम आज तक मुझे समझ में नहीं आई
अभी तक।
ये इसकी प्रॉब्लम भाई
एमएसएफ हैवन क्यों? चलो हो गया। उसके बाद
हम क्या करते हैं? यूज़
एक्सप्लइट
मल्टी हैंडलर
एक्सप्लइट मल्टी हैंडलर
हो गया। नेक्स्ट उसके बाद हम क्या करते
हैं? सेट
पेलोड
विंडोज
X 64
रिवर्स
मे बी इट्स परफेक्टली फाइन
परफेक्टली फाइन। उसके बाद हम क्या करते
हैं? इसको रन करते हैं।
तो एमएसएफ कंसोल भी हमारा रनिंग है और
हमारा सर्वर भी। चलो पैनल भी रनिंग है और
सर्वर भी। चलो एंड ये रहा ये भी रनिंग है।
और इसके अलावा एंड
नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट वर और इसको एक काम करते
हैं हम बाहर निकाल लेते हैं।
व्हाट हैपन?
ओके ये अलग से हो गया। परफेक्टली फाइन।
और इसको एक काम करते हैं।
नेक्स्ट इसका थोड़ा साइज बढ़ा लेते हैं।
थोड़ा इसको ऐसे रखते हैं।
तो अभी एक काम करें इसको डबल क्लिक करें
पहले।
डबल क्लिक
करें गाइस
मैं करता हूं ओपन
जैसे ही ओपन करता हूं नाउ गो टू आवर इनेबल
कंटेंट
ओके व्हाट इज द वार्निंग
हो गया गड़बड़ कर दिया हमने गड़बड़ पीएस
स्क्रिप्ट
चलो आ जाओ वापस से
ऐसे गड़बड़ है तमाम गड़बड़ मिलेंगे ऐसी
और कोई तो नहीं है शेल कमांड
कंट्रोल S इसको फिर से करके देखते
उसके बाद आगे इसको क्लोज करते हैं।
अगेन ओपन और
ओपन
ओके
यह क्या प्रॉब्लम हो गई यार?
पूरी को करते हैं डिलीट। अभी एक काम करते
हैं। पहले इसको ठीक करते हैं।
इसको रन करके देख लेते हैं। इसमें कुछ
मिलने वाला तो है नहीं।
यह सही है नहीं है।
परफेक्टली फाइन। ओके वो भी डिटेक्ट हो
गया।
अब वो डिटेक्ट हो गया। वो चलेगा ही नहीं।
इसी कारण से तो मैं उसको करने वाला नहीं
था।
ओके।
अब पूरा कोड तो हम दोबारा नहीं लिख सकते।
ये हो गया हमारे साथ गड़बड़। [संगीत]
ओके हमें जाने दो भैया।
हमें ओपन करने दो। हमें अपना कोड लेने दो।
पूरा कोड ही गया।
उसको रन किया। कोड गया।
इसमें कुछ है नहीं।
तो गाइज हमारा प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
यहीं पर रुक गया।
मोटा मोटा देखा जाए तो हमारे साथ घटना घट
चुकी है। प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन आज मैं
आपको दिखा ही नहीं पाया। दोबारा कोड लिखने
में उतना ही टाइम लगेगा जितना अभी लगा था।
बिल्कुल सही कह रहे हो। घटना घट गई।
तो घटना घट गई तो एक काम करते हैं। चलो
फिर
कंट्रोल सी
और यह पूरा कोड हमारे पास उधर ही है ना।
चलो
कंट्रोल सी मैं इसका एक काम करता हूं।
कॉपी बनाता हूं। बस मुझे चुपचाप लिखने
देना। मैं लिख देता हूं। अभी फटाफट
और लिख देता हूं।
अभी मेरे पास ऐसी कोई फाइल ही नहीं है जिस
पर मैं क्या करूं?
शेयर कर सकूं।
ओनली पीएस नाम रखता हूं।
क्या हुआ? अभी पूछ रहे हो अनोनिमस
इससे पता चलता है कि क्लास में नहीं आते
आप लोग। मुझे पता है अब मुझे यकीन हो गया।
यहां पर कांड हो गया यार।
विंडो स्टाइल
तो आपका बफर हुआ किधर कोड उड़ गया।
रोक लिया करो भाई बफर होने से।
क्यों मेरी मेहनत दोबारा करवाते हो? हैं?
करवाते हो ना आप लोग मेरी मेहनत
तो मेरे को क्लास में भी आना पसंद नहीं
करते आप। ठीक है। मे बी कंप्लीट कोड हो
चुका है। कंट्रोल एस करता हूं इसको। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं होनी चाहिए। और आई होप कि
सारी मशीनें काम कर रही है। इसको मैं एक
काम कर देता हूं। इसको रन करके देख लेते
हैं पहले। ओके। इसको रन करके देख लेते
हैं। पहले ही गड़बड़ नहीं करेंगे।
परफेक्टली फाइन। सर्वर इज रनिंग। और चलो
एक रिस्क ले। इसको क्लोज करके रिस्क ले
लेता हूं। अभी
और क्लोज करके रिस्क नहीं। मैं इसको कॉपी
करता हूं।
ऐसा तो रिस्क नहीं लूंगा कि मैं कुछ
गड़बड़ हो जाए।
गुड। यहां पे हमने कर लिया। अब की बार
इतना बड़ा रिस्क नहीं लेंगे कि दोबारा कोड
लिखने की अपने पास हिम्मत नहीं है अभी। है
ना?
ओके।
क्लोज
एंड राइट क्लिक ओपन
एंड
व्हाट हैपन
समथिंग इज हैपनिंग समथिंग बैड इज हैपनिंग
हियर चलो एक काम देखते हैं यहां पर कुछ
हुआ
यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट नहीं गई समथिंग बैड इज
हैपनिंग एंड
इसको मैं डायरेक्ट रन करके देखूं।
तो एक काम करते हैं। मै नेम लिखा मैंने
डेमो।
क्यों?
यह क्यों नहीं रन हो सकता?
कंट्रोल ऑल कंट्रोल सी
डोंट सेव चलो
एक नई microsoft फाइल
सेव एज
एम
डेवलपर विजुअल बेसिक
पेस्ट
ट्राई टू रन
टाइप मिसमैच
इसको हटाता हूं मैं। एक काम करता हूं
इसको।
व्हाट इज द इशू इन दैट?
उसके अंदर बहुत बेसिक बताया गया है ब्रो।
क्लब तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में ही होगा। एरर आ
गई है और इसको
इट विल टेक लो। एक काम देख लेते हैं।
इसमें देख लेते हैं इस चीज को फाइंड आउट
करके।
कॉपी एंड
पेस्ट
ओके। यह मिल गई। यह मिल गई।
ये रहा मिल गई
नाउ परफेक्टली फाइन वर्किंग फाइन देखो अभी
काम कर रहा है
ये देखो यहां पर गेट रिक्वेस्ट आया
यहां पे गेट रिक्वेस्ट आया और यहां पर
मीटर फिल्टर सेशन आएगा
आएगा आएगा आएगा अभी अभी नहीं आया। मैं एक
काम करता हूं अभी के लिए। इसको फिर से ऑन
करते हैं। ये रहा
देखना चाहे तो यहां पे विंडो आर टेम
फोल्डर के अंदर हम चेक करते हैं। ये रहा
फाइल.ext नहीं आई अभी तक। वी विल अगेन वी
विल चेक क्या इशू है।
देन इसको हम क्या करेंगे?
रन किया।
यहां फाइल आई या नहीं आई?
ये रही फाइल आई। ये रही
एप्लीकेशन इधर आ गई।
अपडेट exc ओके ऑटोमेटिक डिलीट
अभी भी इसमें कुछ जान बची हुई है।
किसकी वजह से डिलीट हो रही है? ये
देखते हैं हम
फाइल डॉ.txc
देन उसके बाद अगर हम देखेंगे
पेज माय मशीन यह रहा मीटर प्रिट सेशन मिल
गया। ठीक है? ये देखोगे
आईपी कॉन्फिग
व्हाई अगेन इट इज क्लोजिंग
फिर से सेशन क्लोज हो गया बिकॉज़ सम इशू इज़
देयर
फाइल डिलीट हो रही है बार-बार मैं इसको
क्लोज भी किया था
मतलब आपको मैंने दिखा दिया कि इस तरीके से
आप कर सकते हो। पता चल गया आप लोगों को?
पता चल गया आप लोगों को?
तो ड्रॉपर आपको बनाना आ
आपको आईडिया हो गया कि कैसे चीजें काम
करती है। कैसे ड्रॉपर बनाया जाता है वीबीए
के केस में।
किसी को डाउट है?
किसी को कोई भी डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द सेशन
और फिर से आप लोगों के लिए एक वार्निंग
है। अगर आप लोग इतने ही प्रेजेंट होंगे
पांच से सात स्टूडेंट ही आएंगे तो प्लीज
मेरी तरफ से
इस मॉड्यूल के बाद
मैं नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा फिर रिलीज एस्केलेशन
लिटिल मोमेंट फ्री में तो नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
फिर मैं फ्री में बिल्कुल नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
बाद में मेरे को मत बोलना फिर मैं अगेन
वही बोल रहा हूं कि मैं आप लोगों के लिए
इतना कुछ करता हूं तो आप लोग इतना नहीं कर
सकते तो मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
चलिए फिर बाय-ब एवरीवन
गुड नाइट एवरीवन